[موسيقى]
في صحيفه لومون تقرير جاء فيه ان حصيله
الحرب في غزه بعد اكثر من 100 يوم كارثيه
في ظل غياب افق لانهاء الازمه وبينما تغيب
الادله في الواقع على انتقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى مرحله جديده من القتال
يستبعد التقرير ان تكون نتيجه الصراع
مصادفه وينبه الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان
يدرك الخساره الفادحه التي ستلحق به في
غزه لكنه رغم ذلك خاطر بالتسبب في خسائر
فادحه في صفوف
المدنيين في مجله فورين افيرز نقرا مقالا
يرى ان تحقيق السلام يكون فقط من خلال
انهاء اسرائيل احتلالها للاراضي
الفلسطينيه مضيفا ان الحلول المقترحه لحكم
غزه بعد الحرب محكوم عليها بالفشل طالما
تجاهلت القضيه بمفهومها الاوسع المتمثل في
تقرير المصير واقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه حل
مساله غزه يتطلب من اسرائيل معالجه السبب
الجذري للعنف في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
الشرقيه
ايضا نشرت الجارديان مقالا يعتبر ان قضيه
الاباده الجماعيه قدمت ما يكفي لتوضيح مدى
قصور الاستجابه الدوليه تجاه ازمه غزه
بشكل صادم القضيه اظهرت وفق المقال كيف ان
المنطقه الغربيه بدا يضعف وان قدرته على
الاقناع تتراجع في عالم متعدد الاقطاب لا
يستبعد المقال رفض القضيه لكنه يتوقع
ضريبه سيتعين على القوى الغربيه دفعها
تتمثل في فقدان
مصداقيتها وكاله اسوشيتد بريس كتبت ان
حماس جمعت ترسانه متنوعه من الاسلحه من
جميع انحاء العالم تم تهريب الكثير منها
رغم حصار دام 17 عاما كان يهدف الى وقف
مثل هذا الحشد العسكري الوكاله اوضحت ان
حماس تستخدم في القتال بنادق قنص ايرانيه
وبنادق هجوميه من الصين وروسيا وقذائف
صاروخيه مصنوعه في كوريا الشماليه
وبلغاريا وصواريخ مضاده للدبابات تم
تجميعها سرا في غزه ينطلق تقرير في الوست
جونال من اخبار تتحدث عن توجه الحوثيين
نحو ضرب اهداف امريكيه بالبحر الاحمر
ويقول ان هجمات الحوثيين اصبحت اوسع مما
كانت عليه قبل الضربات التي نفذتها القوات
الامريكيه في اليمن بالتعاون مع القوات
البريطانيه فهجت الحوثيين كانت تركز فقط
على السفن المرتبطه باسرائيل
حسب الصحيفه رد القوى الغربيه جعل من
البحر الاحمر نقطه اشتعال جديده بين
الولايات المتحده والجماعات المدعومه من
ايران المنتشره بكثره في
المنطقه